hi everyone thanks for joining we're
going to get started now today we have
dr moore here so we'll turn it over to
him for some brief remarks
good afternoon bon appetit
it has been almost three weeks since
schools resumed in-person learning and
11 days since ontario began its gradual
reopening
and i am pleased to report that our
health care and public health indicators
continue to demonstrate an improvement
in the covid situation in the province
the average for new
covet 19 positive admissions to hospital
continues to decline
as do the total number of patients in
hospital with covet 19.
similarly the average for new admissions
to the intensive care unit and the total
number of patients
with covet 19 in the icu both continue a
downward trend
the percent positivity of pcr tests
continues to decrease
with our average this past week
declining to
13.42 percent from 14.64 percent the
week prior
there are also fewer new outbreaks in
long-term care in hospitals and a
declining number of residents in
long-term care with active covet 19
infection
in addition almost half of all
wastewater samples
in the province are showing a downward
trend in sars kovi ii detections
with the recent decline in covet 19
related hospitalizations in icu
admissions as well as stabilizing health
human resources in many organizations we
are now in a position to lift directive
to to gradually and cautiously resume
non-emergent
and non-urgent surgeries and procedures
in public hospitals
hospitalization
don lesopito public
resumption of these services will follow
a planned
phased approach across the province in
alignment with guidance provided by
ontario health and oversight by regional
officers working with local hospitals
we know the health system is still
strained in some regions and directive
2.1 remains in effect to support patient
transfers to maximize healthcare
capacity across the province
as these services resume it will be
critical that our health system partners
proceed cautiously and continue to
demonstrate the tremendous partnership
and collaboration they have shown to
date so that all regions have the
capacity to resume services slowly
the situation in our schools also
remains encouraging as of february 8
99.9
of publicly funded schools were open
the percentage of school absent absences
was 10.7 percent and almost 2 percent
decreased from the week prior and 8.3
percent of staff were absent
the average total absence rate in the
province was 10.5 percent with five
schools reported as closed
thank you to our educators our parents
and students for their continued
dedication to keeping our schools as
safe as possible for in-person learning
and this includes immunization we
continue to make progress in our
vaccination campaign for our five to 11
year olds
54.7 percent have received one dose and
25.4 percent are fully immunized
and
87.3 percent of youth age 12 to 17 have
received one dose and 83.9 have received
both doses to further increase our
student immunization rates close to 330
school-based clinics will be held by
public health units across the province
by from february 7th to the 20th
and close to 420 school-based clinics
were held from january 17th to february
sixth
with these positive trends and strong
safety measures in place students can
once again benefit from extracurricular
activities including high contact sports
and musical activities such as choir
and wind instrument ensembles
participated only activity
spell the contact and secret days
activity musical
health and safety measures will continue
to be in place including masking
students and other participants will be
required to wear a mask while on school
premises but may temporarily remove it
to enable active participation in
activities such as playing basketball or
to play musical instruments
and i know these activities are critical
for the physical
social and mental well-being of our
children and youth and i'm pleased that
we are now at a point where students in
ontario will once again be able to
access these activities within a school
setting
with respect to our vaccination campaign
i want to thank ontarians for rolling up
their sleeves and incredible 92.1
percent of ontarians age 12 and over
have received one dose of a covet 19
vaccine
89.6 percent have received two doses
this achievement is to be applauded and
i thank everyone who's come forward
6.6 million ontarians have already
received their booster dose booster
doses have been shown to reduce the risk
of severe outcomes from omicron such as
hospitalization and death by around 90
percent
and they have also been shown to be 60
protective against symptomatic disease
i continue to encourage all those
eligible who has still not received a
booster to please get their shot as soon
as possible we have been receiving a lot
of questions about when it's best to
receive a booster dose post covid 19
infection and individuals infected with
covet 19 after their primary series but
before their booster dose are
recommended to receive their booster
dose around three months after symptom
onset or a positive test
this individual
infected
premiere series
emerging evidence indicates that a
longer interval between infection and
vaccination is associated with improved
antibody responses to covet 19
vaccines with informed consent
individuals may receive a booster dose
once they become asymptomatic after
infection and have completed their
isolation
with encouraging trends in community
transmission and our hospitalization and
icu admission trending downwards we can
now see that omicron peak is behind us
this is thanks to the collective efforts
of ontarians following the public health
measures we know work as well as our
high vaccination rates it's now time
that we start focusing on resuming
certain procedures in our health system
as well as the other aspects of our
society that improve our social and well
being
this means that we are actively planning
what the future looks like and laying
out timelines for what public health
measures can be lifted and when
solavedio good new planet
is
19 though is not going away we need to
continue to apply what we have learned
and know what works it's clear that the
situation in ontario today as it relates
to covet 19 is different than when proof
of vaccination and masking requirements
were first introduced and with this in
mind we are looking at the plan to
consider when we can recommend to
government what additional measures can
be eased this includes keeping our mass
on for a while longer and with high
vaccine coverage in the population
planning for when proof of vaccination
can be discontinued this and other
measures would be considered
in re in relation to lifting of other
restrictions
and the ongoing health and safety
measures that would remain in public
settings
our plan has always to be data driven
and follow the best science and the
decisions that we make in the coming
days and weeks will continue to be based
on the best evidence
these discussions are ongoing and we
will have more to say in the coming days
ahead thank you merci
we'll go to the phone lines for
questions just a reminder it's one
question one follow-up over to the first
question please
from chris rushery at the toronto star
hi thanks for taking my question um
community sports resumed for kids a
couple of weeks ago
and high school coaches are saying that
they don't understand why high contact
sports and schools weren't also given
the go-ahead can you explain
why there was a delay for school sports
resuming
i think from a safety vantage point we
had to make sure that all the layers of
safety were in play and were working
well within our school setting uh i i
did see the conflict of community
settings opening up and not having them
available to students in in the school
setting and as a result we've made
direct recommendations to government to
ensure
that they now run in parallel
i'm sorry for any delay in enabling this
but this was to ensure that we had all
the safety protocols in play and that
our school absenteeism rates rates
remained relatively stable
we in addition uh in school settings
continue to have very good safety
protocols uh that would enable this
activity to remain safe
and to be opening up uh in in a
process across all of ontario
thank you yes and with regards to masks
in schools
alberta is ditching them next week
saskatchewan's following suit at the end
of the month and i'm just wondering if
this is something on your radar or do
you expect that masks will be in place
in schools for the remainder of the
school year
thank you for that question so we're
reviewing all public health measures uh
and making recommendations to government
i i would think my initial feeling is
that we keep
initially measures in the school setting
to ensure that parents have confidence
workers have confidence and students
have confidence to go to school
so i anticipate that the the measures
that we may remove at a societal level
will remain in the school setting a bit
longer
to maintain that safety protocol we
don't want to lose any days in school we
want to maintain presenteeism in the
school setting and ensure all children
feel confident and comfortable
in the classroom so
my gut's telling me that we'll delay any
removal of public health measures in the
school setting after we remove them at
a population or community level next
question
from brian lilly at toronto sun
on that note about masks and
vaccine passports you have commented
as recently as last week that vaccine
passports
and other measures are something to
review
what are your thoughts on lifting them
at the community level is that something
in the near future is that something
that we should expect to be added into
the province's reopening plan soon
because currently
out to march 14th there's no mention of
what to do about vaccine passports or
masking should the public expect an
update on that soon
yeah thanks so much brian we will be
reviewing uh the evidence and as i've
said today the evidence is showing we're
making remarkable improvement uh in all
of the key metrics in ontario and that
forces us to re review all public health
measures that are in play none of them
are expected to remain in play longer
than they uh need to be or and or have a
benefit to protect ontarians so we are
reviewing all of them in the coming days
and anticipate we'll make
recommendations to government uh as soon
as next week
and there'll be greater clarity for all
ontarians to understand the processes
that we'll put in play
and the timelines for removal of all
public health measures in a graded
cautious manner which has been the
cornerstone of ontario's approach
follow-up
what would you say to people who
are claiming that some of the provinces
have already moved on
measures because of pressure from the
protests in ottawa at the
uh
the windsor border crossing and
elsewhere and that anything you do now
is just going to be giving in to the the
protesters and therefore you shouldn't
do it you should keep everything in
place
i hope all ontarians are watching the
data as we are
and it is showing a remarkable
and rapid decline in risk to
hospitalization and risk to
get admitted to the intensive care unit
and our approach in ontario has always
been to follow data
and that data is showing very positive
trends and i think as you've said brian
you've heard from me before we will
always follow the data no public health
measure should be in place any longer
than it has to be
and hence
without any external pressure because i
don't really watch the news too much
we are
absolutely committed to removing public
health measures in a timely
evidence-based science-driven science
driven manner
and will be making recommendations to
government next week we'll be monitoring
the trends all weekend but i can't thank
ontarians enough
for continuing to wear their masks wash
their hands get their first second and
third doses it is protecting us it's
protecting our health system and as a
result all of the metrics are improving
dramatically
next question
from cynthia mulligan city news
hi dr moore
uh back to the question of passports
last week you were saying that they do
need to be reviewed but you are also
saying that if you have two shots
that you can still get covered and you
can still pass it on
so if you're going to a restaurant and
and let's say you know 90 percent of
people have two doses
and 10 or some have three doses
is a passport relevant anymore in that
situation to prevent you from getting it
if you only have two doses well i will
reiterate that we have a layered
approach to measures uh within
restaurants and in most public venues
where there's a they're screening for
symptoms
there is
masking when you move and moving within
those facilities you take your mask off
when you sit down so proof of
vaccination is only one
measure of a suite of measures that are
in place to protect all of us
in public spaces and in restaurants bars
and other venues
the utility of them always has to be
asked
and if they are yes less useful over
time and and as a result of
the the
the vaccines they're so beneficial
against severe outcomes um so there is a
place to ensure that people are
vaccinated with the proof of vaccination
i think they've done their job to
protect people in those venues but there
comes a time when we have to reconsider
and review their ongoing utility and as
the risk goes down in our communities
we have to look at removal of proof of
vaccination in in all of those settings
follow-up cynthia
yeah sorry i'm i'm sorry i wasn't sure
if he was finished thank you um so
let me rephrase it a little bit our our
vaccine task force i mean and yes with
the additional measures but should they
either be scrapped or should they be
upgraded to three doses
what would the best
science be on this
so i i think we have to be realistic um
we have 6.6 million ontarians that have
come forward for their third doses we're
not going to hold back uh and mandate uh
through proof of vaccination that uh
five more million ontarians get
immunized with third doses two doses is
exceptionally protective against
admission to hospital
it does protect you against uh
ending up in an intensive care unit and
or death it's done its job protecting
ontarians and because 12 plus we have
over 90 percent protection now
i think it's an a prudent time to review
uh proof of vaccination as one tool in a
multi-layered approach uh for for these
venues
next
question from colin demelo at ctv news
hey good afternoon dr moore so some
people in ontario might be looking at
provinces like alberta and saskatchewan
and wondering uh what is taking ontario
so long so could you outline what is the
difference that you see in alberta for
instance that allows that province to
remove all of its covet 19 restrictions
almost immediately while we take a
slower approach what's the difference
uh to be honest colin i don't spend a
lot of time focusing on alberta or other
provinces i am focused on ontario and i
think our plan is reasonable so if you
recall we've built the date for february
21st of reopening
that date
may be reviewed next week given the
significant improvements in all of the
key metrics in ontario
as well you may recall we had a date of
march 14th for subsequent opening of
mass gathering events i think given the
rapid decline in all our case counts we
will follow ontario data we will make
ontario based plans we will continue to
follow our gradual phased approach it
has worked so well for us
and protected so many ontarians and just
recently has been able to i think
mitigate the the number of ontarians
having to end up in hospital and
intensive care unit settings i thank all
ontarians for their sacrifices uh
because it has helped us all
collectively protect our health system
and we're in a very good position to
reconsider timelines
as well as all public health measures
eventually these are government
decisions
but we will make an ontario focused
ontario-based data-driven science-driven
decision by government in the in the
coming week
okay thank you so it sounds like
those dates that we have the 21st and
the march 14th are
almost no longer going to be in effect
that you could potentially move them up
by a few days if not a week
i'm wondering so what can businesses
expect here capacity is that going to be
moved up or what measures are you
willing to speed up and which will be
the last to return so a large sporting
event would that be the last to return
capacity limits could that be sped up
give us give us your your take on dates
and what could change i i would look at
um the dates that have been provided feb
february 21st uh and march 14th all
those measures that would be opened it
it's now given
how well ontario's done in the omicron
wave how well
our health system is recovering uh i i
would assume government wants and will
review timelines as well as all public
health measures including when we remove
proof of vaccination when we remove
masking in certain venues i do think
masking in public indoor spaces like
transit subways buses
will be maintained
until we really have very low endemicity
and that would be cases below 10 per 100
000
on a weekly average
which would have correlates with
hospitalization uh and icu
utilization as well
follow-up
i already have my two you can go to this
thank you last question
from holly mackenzie suiter canadian
press
hi dr moore i just wanted to get a
little more clarity on you said you're
reviewing
all public health measures including the
vaccine passports and mask mandates in
some settings so if you recommend ending
those measures could that potentially
happen before the end of the reopening
timeline
in march or whenever it ends up being
yeah thanks holly so i i can't presume
what eventual government decisions will
be made um but i think a review of all
timelines
is absolutely appropriate in the face of
the improving data in ontario
and removal of
decisions on them we want to be
transparent to businesses transparent to
ontarians on what can be expected in
terms of the timelines um
our we made the best estimates on
february 21st and um march 14th based on
uh modeling it's just
that our situation has improved uh and
no one wants uh to impede businesses any
more than we have to
nor do we want public health measures a
minute longer as the premier would say
then aren't necessary and that is our
commitment to all ontarians
follow-up and this is the last question
yeah i'm just wondering you mentioned uh
surgeries gradually resuming um
following this phased approach across
the province but i'm wondering if you
can give more detail on like what that
phased approach is going to look like is
it going to be different depending on
the situation and kind of what order
you expect procedures are going to start
in thank you so much holly so we need to
brief all of our health system partners
and i i do believe ontario health has
been doing that aggressively
we
don't want to suddenly open up all the
doors
and have our hospitals busy we really
need uh and to understand some hospitals
are still quite busy with uh covid
activity and there are regional
variations in the level of
covid across ontario and we need to work
as a system supporting
each other all hospitals
are long-term care and public health
trying to ensure that patients can be
provided the right care at the right
time at the right place so
it will not be sudden it will be gradual
as our plan is in ontario phased
monitored and we want to move up to
around 70 surgical capacity and that is
those that have been waiting for a new
knee a new hip cataract surgeries those
we want to return
gradually without significantly
impacting the system to ensure that we
are able to provide care to in those
regions where there is increased covet
activity and also to provide equity
across ontario
so we will do it in those phased
approaches of around 70 of their
surgical
capacity keeping that availability for
covid patients then move up to around 90
percent surgical capacity and then when
we're in a recovery phase which we
anticipate being in in late march and
april uh opening up surgeries back to
normal normal volumes to uh then try to
also do some catch up on any procedures
that were significantly delayed so i
hope everyone's hearing staged phased
evidence-based cautious approaches
are the mainstay in ontario of how to
return the health system back to
recovery
thanks everyone